interesting Paul came out from the good
folks over at Pew they're doing a ton of
research over there and Americans we
don't think America's number one and the
great numbers that we used to let's look
at some info here so the study found
that just 28% believe that the u.s.
stands above all other countries in the
world which is compared to 38% back in
2011 sighs a 10% drop in just a couple
years fifty-eight percent say it's one
of the greatest countries in the world
along with some others and twelve
percent say that there are other
countries that are better some 52% said
America stood above the others in 2011
that's now dropped to 37% and just a
couple other little points of
information for you they also found that
Americans 18 to 29 or at the bottom of
those who view the nation as standing
alone in greatness just 15% of those
under 30 expressed that view today which
is down from 27% just a couple years ago
all right so let's start here why is it
that Republicans seem to love America
more even though their numbers are
dropping and have actually dropped more
than Democrats in these last couple
years
why don't repulse country more than you
crazy Democrats what's going on Cathy
they don't love it more they just like
to wave the flag more yeah I mean I have
nothing to do with with what they really
think of it they are just you know who
think who the hell cares who's number
one anyway I mean what kind of [ __ ]
is that
well we're number one in keeping our own
citizens in prison sure crime rates
murder rates I'm sure all of those
things to obesity whereby yeah carbon
emissions I thought you were gonna go to
our that may not be true now with India
yeah I mean but you know it's always the
people who were waving the flag you know
the hardest or the longest who just you
know or really don't understand what's
going on in this country you don't
really get the full picture you know
there's the defensive is what they are
defensive yes there's some is there
weird thing like I love this country I
think I believe in American
exceptionalism cuz we've had people from
all over the world come here to try to
make a better life but the reason I'm so
critical of the country is because I
love it so I think that they sort of
view it as if you're critical they look
at people that are critical of our
policies and think well you don't like
what we are [ __ ] exceptionalism anyway
well I mean that to me is is it that's
that doesn't have a good send a good
signal well remember during the election
the first time in 2008 they asked Obama
if he believed in American
exceptionalism and he said I believe in
it just as Greeks probably believed in
Greek exceptionalism the only difference
is we're a nation that's made up purely
of immigrants so I do think there is
something special there well I think
there's a there's also a fine line
between sort of patriotism and
nationalism right this is always the
fine line that I think some in this
country the left I mean the right sort
of veer too far to the side which is you
know they're all I hope Patriots you
know I mean then this country is
incredibly exceptional and in the sense
that it's built by immigrants that you
have the freedom to criticize that we
can make a show like this those things
are all pretty extraordinary and and we
should be critical because that is what
our role is right yeah that's the whole
part of this you know they don't they
don't they think it ends just by loving
it
being critical of it is what makes it so
great that's right that no and and also
it's those guys who were seeing you know
America love it or leave it who also
right below that bumper sticker have
those nudie mud flaps are you really
gonna listen to that it's a lot well now
we've lost our viewer in Kentucky do you
think there's a danger though for the
young people that their numbers are
pretty low do you think there's a weird
danger for them not to think America's
number one like I remember growing up
and it was so obvious America's number
one you can do anything you want
etc etc and then I really can't know but
that you when you grow up with at least
that idea there's I think there's
something good about that that if you
think that the country you're living in
is number one that you can do something
you can just is that just is that just
childish I don't feel that it's
important to rank yea the country
I think it's important to to build a
good country and be good citizen and
question things and make things better I
didn't really think it's important where
you rank internationally I think that's
like it's like the Olympics of course
it's just ESPN of you know the world I
think that it's special that in in this
country if you work really hard I mean
it helps to be from a certain you know
economic background in the beginning but
it can work really hard you can make
something really special when you look
at the impact that you know even you
know immigrants have made in the tech
scene especially in Silicon Valley
people have just recently come to this
country what they've done and how
transformative that's what's really
special so to me like the fact that
maybe kids don't think that we're number
one that doesn't matter so much but I
wouldn't want them ever to lose the fact
that if you work really really hard you
can do something really special and
transform it and I think that part of
part of the problem and what's happened
in America before is is that American
Dream gets skewed where you think if I I
might get lucky and become a millionaire
or strike oil and then all of a sudden
I'm a millionaire and that idea is like
I can be as rich as anybody else like I
can be whoever it is Elon Musk or
whoever it is but like the reality is
you can't be that unless you are willing
to dedicate so much of your time energy
into doing something and it's not all
about money
yeah it's not about money and I and I
really I I hope this stress can be taken
off of that it has to do with
contributing yeah it doesn't have to do
with getting yeah you know what you did
not like iran's books did you I didn't